or researchers at the Johns Hopkins
University in the US are mapping the
spread of the virus the bright orange
dots here show the areas in China where
cases have been confirmed the majority
of those are in Hebei province where the
first outbreak was reported millions of
people in China now face
travel restrictions and around the world
they've been confirmed cases in several
countries joining us here in the studio
is the division chief of pathology
Sciences at Sidra Medicine here in Qatar
dr. Patrick tang good to every with us
in the studio Patrick as an expert in
the field how concerned are you about
this virus and its potential to spread I
think as with many experts in this field
right now we're watching very closely
what happens in China with a fair degree
of concern definitely it is a public
health emergency in China for the rest
of the world it's it's a moderate
concern and we're definitely watching it
closely to make sure that it doesn't get
out of China you dealt with the the SARS
outbreak when that happened how does
this coronavirus compared to the virus
that was responsible for sickening so
many people with with SARS and other
similar methods you use to control
something like this so from what we know
so far about this novel coronavirus in
China it's it's probably less lethal
than SARS so of the people that get
infected with this virus about three
percent of them die whereas from saw
during SARS about ten percent of the
people that got infected died from the
infection in terms of infective nasai
receive as infectious as SARS if not
more infectious than SARS at least based
on what we know right now is that when
the Chinese government says that the
virus is spreading faster is that what
you mean it's infectious to us it's the
ease of transmission between people I
mean is it transmissible
person-to-person so so we know now that
it is transmission from person to person
what we're trying to determine is how
infectious is how many people are
infected by every case that has the
virus so right now we believe it's
somewhere between 2 to 3 people will get
infected from every one case that we
okay so at the moment those of us who
aren't in China don't have that much to
worry about yet but it's in flu
influenza season anyway that BAP too is
a corona virus right the influenza is
not a groaner
okay okay but the common cold is a
corona by so there's many corona viruses
yes for common ones that are corona
virus and they cause common colds okay
so how do we protect ourselves from bugs
that are in our general enviable they're
not bugs they're viruses aren't they
mm-hmm so so we have to for the regular
person that's not in China right now
that we have to use common-sense
measures so things like you know washing
your hands it's probably the most
important thing that we can do to
prevent infection from this novel
coronavirus or other respiratory
infections and and paying attention to
how what we do with our hands whether we
touch your eyes and rubber nose or or
put our fingers in our mouths so all of
these things are things that can carry
different pathogens into our body what
about the mosques that we see people
wearing on the footage from China and
from Hong Kong how how useful are those
in protecting you from viruses that may
be around us and in the air is this is
this virus transmissible through coughs
and sneezes in the in the air or is it
visit by touch do we know that yet so
this novel coronavirus is spread through
droplets so as people Kaufer or other
respiratory secretions are emanate from
them it can cause infections and other
people near them so the mass does play
some role it's it's somewhat
controversial because some experts would
argue that the mask don't give you 100%
protection from the virus and that that
is true but but there is a fair degree
of protection and some people might
argue there's about maybe 7080 percent
protection and and that might be good
enough for the regular people and the
other thing that the mask do is it
raises awareness of the disease so so
when people start wearing masks and more
people are aware that of the disease and
they take more common sense precautions
against that and one more question to
you as a scientist you you you call this
that the novel coronavirus where did
this come from it by novel we mean that
but it hasn't existed before did it
mutate in form from another
I mean how does things like this appear
in the environment
so after SARS scientists went out to
find out what was the source of SARS and
from all the studies done in China they
they found that these corona viruses
live in bats so there there are hundreds
if not more different variants of SARS
viruses corona viruses that live in bats
and an any number of them might have
mutations that allow them to causing
actions in people so if we have the
unfortunate juxtaposition of all these
different events where you have a virus
in a bat that has the right mutations
and it happens to encounter a human
being then you can establish a human
advantage one quick question about the
possibility of it mutating once once it
is in an in it's in capable of infecting
humans could could it could it mute a
can get worse yes it could so so that is
what we're trying to do right now so
everywhere I want around the world both
in China as well as the rest of the
world we're trying to contain this virus
so it doesn't have a chance to spread
between human to human because every
chance that spreads from one person to
the next is a chance for the virus to
further adapt and further mutate to
become a virus at that because it's a
human virus actually it's been great to
talk to you many thanks indeed for
coming to see us at at al-jazeera dr.
Patrick tang there